GET STARTED. THIS IS THE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY UTILITIES
AND COMMUNICATIONS. WE'RE GOING
TO BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE OF
THE. HAVE A FORUM AND HEAR
TESTIMONY ON AS JERRY LEVIN.
SENATOR MORE LOCAL THE
PRESIDING FOR CENTER BATES.
THAT'S A MONTH FEEDBACK. THANK
YOU MISTER ONE WAS THE
MICROPHONE WORKS I WILL
CONTINUE BUT IF IT DOES GIVE
FEEDBACK I'LL JUST TURN IT OFF.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR CAUGHT. I AM PRESENTING
ON BEHALF OF SENATORS BATES
REMINDING WHO. AND GIVE ME THIS
PRIVILEGE TODAY TO PRESENT
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION ELEVEN.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
TO ADD CO AUTHORS. COLLEAGUES
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
NUCLEAR WASTE POLICY ACT WAS
SIGNED INTO LAW REQUIRING WITH
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO BEGIN
ACCEPTING NUCLEAR WASTE BY
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT. THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS FAILED
TO FULFILL ITS RESPONSIBILITY.
AND THERE HAS BEEN NO
SUBSTANTIAL PROGRESS TOWARD
CONSOLIDATED STORAGE OF USED
CIVILIAN NUCLEAR FUEL. EXISTING
LAW ONLY ALLOWS FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO TAKE POSSESSION
OF HIGH LEVEL RADIOACTIVE WASTE.
SPENT NUCLEAR FUEL WHEN IT IS
ASSIGNED TO PERMANENT STORAGE
AND THERE'S CURRENTLY NO VIABLE
PLAN FOR SUCH PERMANENT STORAGE.
S. J. R. ELEVEN WOULD URGE
CONGRESS TO PASS AND THE
PRESIDENT TO SIGN HR TWO NINE
NINE FIVE. THE SPENT FUEL
PRIORITIZATION ACTIVE TWENTY
NINETEEN. HR TWO NINE NINE FIVE
PRIORITIZE IS THE REMOVAL OF
SPENT NUCLEAR FUEL. FROM
DECOMMISSIONED NUCLEAR SITES IN
AREAS WITH LARGE POPULATIONS
AND HIGH SEISMIC HAZARD WITH
OVER NINE MILLION PEOPLE WITHIN
FIFTY MILES OF THE SENATE NO
FREE NUCLEAR GENERATION
STATION. AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCING SOME OF
THE GREATEST SEISMIC HAZARD IN
THE COUNTRY THE BILL WOULD MAKE
SONGS WHICH IS THE ACRONYM FOR
THE SENATE NO FREE NUCLEAR
GENERATION. STATION ONE OF THE
HIGHEST PRIOR SITES IN THE
NATION. FOR THE STRATEGIC
SHIPPING FOR THE SPENT NUCLEAR
FUEL REMOVAL ADDITIONALLY AS J.
R. ELEVEN ASK FOR THE DIABLO
CANYON NUCLEAR POWER PLANT TO
BE PRIORITIZED AS IT IS ALSO
LOCATED IN AN AREA OF GREAT
SEISMIC THIRD. FOR CALIFORNIA
TO SPEAK WITH ONE VOICE ASKING
CONGRESS TO ADDRESS THE URGENT
ISSUE OF NUCLEAR STORAGE. AND
THEREFORE MISTER CHAIR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR JOHN
THE KLAN BEHALF THE COUNTY SAN
DIEGO ONE OF THE COUNTIES
IMPACTED BY THE CENTER FOR A
NUCLEAR POWER PLANT WE- URGE
YOUR SUPPORT OF US IT J. R.
ELEVEN AND- FINDING SOME TYPE
OF PERMANENT SOLUTION FOR THE
STORAGE OF THE SPENT NUCLEAR
FUEL. THANK YOU. SEN THE
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF FAVOR OR
A OPPOSITION ANYONE IN ANY
SPEAKERS ANYBODY INTERESTED IN
MAKING COMMENTS CENTER STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
MORNING SENATOR MORE LOCK I
MEAN THE FULL SUPPORT OF THE
RESOLUTION BUT JUST OUT OF
CURIOSITY YOU MAY BE THE
CONSULTANT CAN EDUCATE ME. WHAT
IS THE- AMOUNT OF FUEL THAT IS
SITTING THAT. OTHERWISE COULD
NOT EVEN BE IS FOR A GENERATION
OF ELECTRICITY AND- WHERE DO WE
MOVE THE RADIOACTIVE ROD
MATERIAL I KNOW THERE'S A DEPOT
IN NEVADA I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S WHERE IT ALL GOES OR IS
OF A DESTINATION FOR THIS
PRODUCT ONCE WE GET RID OF IT
THE BEST INTERESTS OF NINE
MILLION PEOPLE THAT YOU
ARTICULATED. THANK YOU SENATOR
STONE YOU'VE JUST AT QUESTION
WHAT HAPPENED SPECIFIC ANSWER
BY PAUL DOES I DO NOT KNOW HOW
MUCH. YOU THEIR RIGHTS WERE
DEALING. I KNEW DO KNOW THAT
THEIR- BUSY DE COMMISSIONING
AND FREE AND THAT THERE'S BEEN
A LOT OF INTEREST IN WHAT'S
OCCURRING IN TRYING TO. MOVE
THOSE RIDES INTO A MAJOR
CONCERN OF THE- PUBLIC BECAUSE
THERE WAS AN INCIDENT. IN THE
LAST YEAR SO. SO I BUT I DON'T
FOR THE STATE PERCENT FREE FOR
THE NATION THE SPENT FUEL SELF
I APOLOGIZE I DON'T HAVE THAT
DATA OKAY. THIS I WOULD ASSUME%
THAT MISTER TERRY YOU PROBABLY
KNOW BETTER BEING THE CHAIRMAN
OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR A LONG
TIME THAT I'M SURE THE DOCTORS
PRESCRIBED. WAYS IN WHICH YOU.
SAFEGUARDING TRANSPORT THIS
NUCLEAR FUEL TO ITS ULTIMATE
DESTINATION I THINK I MIGHT BE
IN NEVADA WHERE WE HAVE A-
NATIONAL SITE THAT. I KNOW THE
BALANCE DON'T LIKE BUT I
BELIEVE THAT IS THE SITE OF
WERE THESE DEPOSITIONS ARE MADE
AND APPRECIATE THE RESOLUTION
OF JUST. BUT THE FEDERER
NATIONS ARE AND- ARE ARE IN
ORDER THAT A- THAT ENSURE THAT
THE SAFE TRANSPORT AND DELIVERY
AND- XIN OF THESE MATERIALS.
THEIR ULTIMATE DESTINATION WITH
THAT ALL OF THE BILL. WITH THAT
AND- CHALLENGES OF NUCLEAR.
AMERICA SINCE SINCE THEY'VE
BEGUN PRODUCING NUCLEAR POWER.
INITIALLY IT WAS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WAS CHARGED WITH
FINE. HELLO OKAY. TO STORE. THE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS THAT'S BEEN
SOMETHING. CHRIS AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN ABLE ON A
ABLE TO DO. SO EVERY FACILITY
IN AMERICA STORY AND THEIR
THEIR- THEIR WASTE. ON LOCATION
BECAUSE THERE'S NO WAY TO TAKE
IT SO THE CITY TIMEBOMB NO AND
FORTY MILLION TODAY'S ERA OF
TERRORISM ETCETERA SO AND AGAIN
MAINLY I MEAN. THIS IS BEN
WRITTEN INTO LAW THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL WILL
EVENTUALLY COME UP WITH A
SOLUTION AND NUCLEAR POWER BUT
AS WE HAVE PLANTS PRODUCE IN.
NUCLEAR POWER IN THE COUNTRY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT STILL
HASN'T COME UP WITH A SOLUTION
THAT WAS. YOU KNOW THE LAWS
THAT IMPLEMENTED THE ABILITY TO
CREATE NUCLEAR POWER IN
AMERICA. HAD THAT IN THEIR
INITIAL. INTENSE SO THIS IS
GONNA BE A TOUGH ONE IT'S GOOD
TO. FIND A WAY TO SECURE. WE
NEED WE DEFINITELY NEED TO WORK
ON THAT THERE WAS. FINANCE AND
AS SOON AN OFFER THAT COULD
HAVE BEEN. OF POTENTIALLY
HARMFUL NO AND. AND I THINK
MEASURES ARE BEING TAKEN NOW
FEATURES JUST THAT WAY SO LEASE
MAKE IT EARTHQUAKE PROOF FOR
DISASTER PROOF AROUND TOO MUCH
TO WHAT EXTENT WE COULD DO THAT
I MEAN. LUCKILY WE DON'T GET
SADDAM IS AND CAL. ONE AT THAT
FACILITY WOULD STAND A TSUNAMI.
RIGHT ON THE COAST. THE WELL
WE'RE GONNA ESTABLISH. A QUORUM
CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WESTERN HERE HUESO HERE
MOORLACH AS IN MORE LIKE
PRESENT BRADFORD CHIANG CHAIN
HERE DOT DOT HERE HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG HERE HILL YOUR HILL
HERE MCGUIRE REVEALS. HERE
RUBIO HERE SKINNER STERN STONE.
STONE HERE WIENER. BUT. VERY
WELL DID YOU WANT TO MAKE ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS THE COMMISSION
HERE YOU DID A GREAT JOB OF
ANSWERING CENTER STONE'S
INQUIRE RE CENTER STONE IT WE
HAVE SEVENTEEN HUNDRED TONS OF
SPENT NUCLEAR FUEL ONSIDE SONGS
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS THE
REST OF THE NATION BUT. IN BOTH
BEING COUNTY SUPERVISORS WE
HAVE THE OPERATING CENTER AND
WHEN YOU GO TO THE. A MERGING
OPERATING CENTER FOR K. ORANGE
COUNTY. SANTA ANA MOUNTAINS UP
BY WHAT'S CALLED LEVERAGE. WE
HAVE WALLS WITH POSTERS OF MAPS.
IT ALSO HAS ALL THESE. CITRIX
CIRCLE AND THEY ALL ORIGINATED
FROM SONGS FROM SENATE OVER
FEDERAL WORK HOW MANY YOU KNOW
HOW CLOSE ARE WE YOU KNOW
WHAT'S THE RANGE FROM THE
NUCLEAR POWER PLANT. IN MY A
LOT OF THE FUNDING FOR OUR
MERSEY OPERATING CENTER COMES
FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON. THAT'S SORT OF THE
BIGGEST. EXPOSURE ELEMENT FIT
THAT. RESIDENTS OF ORANGE
COUNTY FACES THIS PARTICULAR.
OF FACILITIES SO. IT JUST
VISITING OUR OPERATING CENTER
RIDGE OPERATE HERE WILL SHOW
YOU HOW CRITICAL THIS IS SO WE
NEED TO DO A LITTLE MATCHING
MISTER CHAIR WITH CONGRESS TO
SAY HEY. YOU YOU'VE HAD THIS
THIS LAW IN PLACE. FOR A COUPLE
DECADES LET'S START. MOVING THE
STRUCTURES OF LEADERSHIP YEAH
THAT'S SAID THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
ENCOURAGING I REQUEST AND I
BOTH THANK YOU AND THIS BILL
DOES DO THAT. I'M SO THAT'S WHY
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WE HAVE A
MOTION. TO BE ADOPTED AS
AMENDED AS CHAIR ELEVEN BATES
WAS SO I WAS SO I AM MORE LACK
MORE LIKE I BRADFORD CHIANG
CHING AYE DODD DODD AYE
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE HILL
HILL AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
RUBIO. RUBIO AYE SKINNER STERN
STONE STONE AYE WIENER WIENER
AYE. SOME REMEMBER GARCIA. WAS
THERE A PROCESS HERE IS THE
JUST. WE HAVE A LETTER FROM
YOUR OFFICE CORRECT EXPRESS
SEASON. QUESTION NAY
RECONSIDERATION RECONSIDERATION
AND ASSEMBLY WE CAN JUST GO
GRANT CONSIDERATE
RECONSIDERATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANYBODY HAVE ANYTHING THE
COMMENT SAY WE HAVE A MOTION
CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
FIFTY SIX GARCIA MOTION FOR
RECONSIDERATION WHAT'S SO
WHAT'S SO ARE A LOT MORE LIKE
AYE BRADFORD CHIANG CHING AYE
DODD DODD AYE HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE HILL HILL AYE
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE RUBIO
RUBIO AYE SKINNER STERN. DOWN
STONE AYE WIENER. HI. WHERE
ADJOURNED WITH WITH THE BILLS
ARE OUT DO WE HAVE ANY. ABSENT
MEMBERS. I WILL WAIT WILL KEEP
THE ROLE OF TRAPS MEMBERS. YEAH.
OKAY IN ORDER FOR
. OKAY. BONTA
TASK. OKAY WE'RE GONNA OPEN UP
THE ROLE OF PROPS OF MEMBERS ON
RECONSIDERATION FREEBIE FIFTY
SIX SENATOR AND I'M SORRY CLERK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AB FIFTY
SIX MOTION FOR RECONSIDERATION
CARVE OUT ZERO. M. INNER ALL
RIGHT SKINNER AYE STERN.
THERE'S A PHONE ON S. JERRY
LEVIN CLERK PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AS CHAIR ELEVEN
BATES TO BE ADOPTED AS AMENDED
CURRENT VOTE TEN ZERO SKINNER
ALL RIGHT SKINNER AYE STERN.
VERY WELL OF THOSE BILLS ARE
OUT WILL CLOSE ROLE OUR
MEETINGS TO TURN